[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous exceptionnellement et en
raison de l'importance de l'actualité et
de la gravité des événements vous me
retrouvais donc en studio pas de samedi
chez vous aujourd'hui
il devait avoir lieu porte de la
chapelle avec frédéric fajardie auteur
de romans policiers
nous le retrouverons samedi prochain 13
décembre mais d'ores et déjà nous le
remercions de sa compréhension
l'actualité prime tout donc un jeune
homme de 22 ans malek oussékine
étudiants à dauphine est mort cette nuit
rue monsieur le prince à paris le
mouvement de protestation des étudiants
et des lycéens de france a tourné au
drame
68 et 86 qui pourtant ne se ressemblent
pas on donc aujourd'hui un point commun
la mort plusieurs témoins ont vu la
scène dramatique et met en cause le
comportement de la police la nuit
terrible du quartier latin par nicolas
jacobs patrick voix et françois corner
ce sont ces brigades motorisées de la
préfecture de police le peloton
voltigeurs motocyclistes chargé de
nettoyer les rues qui est ce matin mis
en cause sur chaque moto en majorité
tout terrain capable de se faufiler
partout et de grains fait facilement sur
les trottoirs deux hommes l'un pilote
l'eau est armé d'une matraque l'objectif
de l'unité commandée par un officier de
police et de surprendre d'intervenir
très vite dans un quartier contre les
casseurs et d'impressionner le plus
possible de l'adversaire pour le
déstabiliser
en principe les petits komodo isolé
d'étudiants ou plus souvent de faux
étudiants ne se frotte pas ce genre
d'unité évite l'affrontement direct avec
cette brigade très impressionnante et
très mobile dans le feu de l'action il
ya malheureusement parfois des bavures
des claques ou les coups de matraque
pleuvent sur des gens qui n'ont souvent
rien à voir avec les casseurs que s'est
il passé la nuit dernière rue monsieur
le prince dans le 6e arrondissement
un groupe de manifestants replier sur le
quartier latin pour l'évacuation dans le
calme de la sorbonne par les portes de
l'eure
dressent des barricades et incendié des
voitures à l'angle de la rue de
vaugirard et de la rue monsieur le
prince une patrouille motorisée
intervient pour dégager la rue c'est au
moment de cette intervention qu'un jeune
homme de 22 ans malik oussékine
étudiants dauphine est né à versailles
va prouver la mort malgré les efforts
des sauveteurs pour le réanimer
arrêt cardiaque consécutive aux coups
portés par les policiers
arrêt cardiaque dû à la peur une enquête
est ouverte par l'inspection générale
des polices la police des polices pour
déterminer les circonstances exactes du
décès de ce jeune étudiant
mais pour l'instant les témoignages sont
accablants ce matin les frais reculent
un des moyens des foutus au balcon puis
là j'ai vu un gros de troupes de crs qui
descendait la rue sur les manifestants
qui eux se sont tirés dans la rue un fou
que les crs sont restés tels que
secondes et puis on continue à les
poursuivre et à ce moment là quelques
secondes après et encore j'ai vu trois
crs sortir de cet immeuble avec un mec
qu'ils ont littéralement tabassés de
façon extrêmement violente extrêmement
violente au milieu au milieu on est de
tourner de tout le monde
puis à ce moment là je suis descendu et
puis quand je suis redescendu j'ai revu
encore les crs qui ne prenait pas le
revers du col qui l'ont balancé sur 3
mètres lemaitre s'est remis de ses
émotions
et le plus triste là dedans c'est qu' il
s' est redirigé vers l'immeuble d'où il
a été sorti et à composer le code ce qui
indiquait que c'est un résident et les
crs sont restés dix minutes sur place et
tous les étudiants étaient planqués dans
les immeubles et à côté et il était
vraiment tapi derrière cette grille et
on voyait manifestement que vous avez
vraiment la trouille
et
une fois que les crs ont pâti de son
parti le penser qu'à la porter secours
aux mecs
le samu est arrivé on a vu les pompiers
qui étaient complètement affolée regard
de ses passions la victime a été
transportée à l'hôpital cochin il ne
sera certainement pas compliqué de
savoir si les normes à dix coups c'est
qu'il a reçu des coups mais pour
l'instant les médecins du samu qui sont
intervenus sur place ces replis derrière
le secret professionnel
[Musique]
bien sûr les considérer comme les
conditions de l'accident de l'incidence
de la maladie sont à prendre en compte
pour savoir l'évolution de la maladie
mais de toute façon dans ce cas là comme
joli du tout à l'heure il ya information
judiciaire je ne peux répondre à vos
questions
nous avons pris en charge un patient qui
avait besoin de besoin nous l'avons
conduit à l'hôpital cochin
tout pourtant avaient été prévenus la
nuit dernière pour éviter ce genre
d'incidents violents
la sorbonne avait été évacué en douceur
en souplesse par les crs ces jeux
suivants n'avaient pas tous des allures
d'étudiant lit d'ailleurs de casseurs
tout avait été prévu sauf ce qui a
peut-être été un dérapage mais le
dérapage est malheureusement souvent
imprévisible bonsoir tout ce qui s'est
passé depuis hier depuis l'intervention
télévisée du ministre on est monory
ouvrant un droit de réplique ce soir
vous l'avez vue ressemble à une
accélération dramatique de la tension
entre les étudiants et le gouvernement
voici les faits c'était cette nuit dans
le quartier latin jeune homme de 22 ans
est violemment frappé par des policiers
membres de la brigade mobile
il décède d'un arrêt cardiaque le
procureur de la république dirait
aujourd'hui que sa mort est due à une
décompensation cardiaque
créé par un état pathologique rénale
antérieur le jeune malik oussékine et
est dialysé
cependant plusieurs témoignages
concordants on rapportait depuis cette
nuit le matraquage auquel il a été
soumis avec françois corner et patrick
voix et le service d'information
générale de la rédaction antenne 2 voici
ce que nous avons pu reconstituer de
faits avérés
le massage cardiaque restera sans effet
malik oussékine va mourir effectivement
d'une compensation cardiaque selon les
premiers éléments de l'autopsié la
victime a pourtant reçu des coups c'est
visible
de nombreux témoins de la firme mais
aucun des hématomes subi selon le
parquet ne semble expliquer seule la
mère du jeune homme ait aucune fracture
toujours selon le parquet n'a pu être
décelée à la radiographie un point
semble pourtant clair il a bien été
matraqué rue monsieur le prince alors
qu'il tentait de se réfugier dans un
immeuble poursuivis par les forces de
l'ordre
un témoin capital paul baysse nous
fonctionnaire au ministère des finances
entendu cet après-midi par ses
enquêteurs doligé est ce que nous allons
voir la police de polices formelle
rentrant chez lui il a essayé de faire
entrer malik oussékine dans l'immeuble a
voulu rentrer donc cher
ce n'était pas ça fait un bon j'ai
ouvert la porte pour laisser entrer et
j'ai fermé la porte aux crs mais cela a
malheureusement avait
milan 20 trains qu'entre les deux
battants des portes dont il n'empêche la
porte ils ont forcé le passage
j'ai résisté pour pas qu'ils rentrent et
ont ils été trop vite et beaucoup plus
fort que moi donc les mêmes discussions
passé ce qui s'est passé à ce moment là
et se sont précipités sur je crois que
sap lémanique
[Musique]
huit coups de matraque et copines et
moi j'ai reçu
que ces coups de matraque sur la tête
les policiers mis en cause font partie
de ces brigades motorisées de la
préfecture de police ce peloton
voltigeurs motocyclistes étaient
intervenus la nuit dernière le quartier
latin à la suite d'incidents provoqués
par des manifestants après l'évacuation
de la sorbonne par les forces de l'ordre
la mission de cette unité composée de
volontaires et d'intervenir pour éviter
par surprise en impressionnant le plus
possible adversaire pour le déstabiliser
malik oussékine était-il au nombre de
manifestants rien ne permet pour
l'instant de l'affirmer mais ils ont été
pris dans la nasse et n'a pas pu s'en
sortir
un autre témoin raconte j'ai vu un
groupe de crs qui descendait la rue sur
les manifestants qui se sont tirés dans
la rue
pas fou qu'il essaierait sont restés
peut-être que secondes et puis on
continue à les poursuivre et à ce moment
là quelques secondes après encore j'ai
vu transférer sortir de cet immeuble
avec un mec qu'ils ont littéralement
tabassés de façon extrêmement violente
extrêmement violente au milieu au milieu
on est de tourner de tout le monde même
si les coûts ne soit pas officiellement
la cause du décès de malik oussékine un
jeune homme de 22 ans est quand même
heure ici dans des circonstances qu'il
est bon d'être éclaircis
nos jeunes malik oussékine mort la nuit
dernière est un beurre il est né il ya
22 ans à versailles est d'origine
algérienne il était étudiant à l'école
supérieure des professions immobilières
à paris et participer occasionnellement
aux activités sportives de l'université
paris dauphine
le frère de malik oussékine est le
propriétaire de la chambre qu'il
occupait témoigne à pascal deschamps je
suis bouleversée consterné et je suis
encore sous le choc je serai pas vous
dire grand chose encore j'ai mal j'ai
mal
est ce que vous savez si votre frère
participaient au mouvement étudiant
récents on écoute est un étudiant il
était concernée est concernée par par ce
qui se passait mais je n'étais pas du
tout un garçon violent
il a fait des ennuis de santé des ennuis
cardiaques
non non il avait
effectivement de santé mais
c'est un sportif et il faisait des 10
sport a assez assez fatigant et n'avait
pas problème de 2k l'extérieur sang qui
gicle le sait depuis
non seulement je vais louer une chambre
d'étudiant car il était étudiant et nous
parle urbaine par trois de ses études et
ses orientations futures
il était parti comme présentation kenny
politesse gentillesse de tous autres
soignées
[Musique]
l'apparence et jamais je me réceptionner
le plus important d'être militant de ni
le rpr ni l'udf ni le front national
n'ont exprimé leurs sentiments
par la voix de philippe séguin ministre
des affaires sociales le gouvernement à
parler à la tribune de l'assemblée
avec pascal guimier je vous propose
maintenant d'écouter l'essentiel des
réactions politiques de ce matin le
gouvernement exprime lui-même son
émotion à la suite du décès d'un jeune
homme survenu cette nuit dans des
circonstances non encore éclaircies
à l'occasion d'incidents qui se sont
produits dans certains quartiers de
paris
ces incidents paraissent dans l'état
actuel de son information avoir origine
les initiatives de petits groupes
incontrôlés
en effet les manifestations regroupant
entre vingt et trente mille personnes
qui ont eu lieu hier après-midi dans les
rues de la capitale n'avait elle-même
donné lieu à aucun incident et de même
l'évacuation de la sorbonne laquelle il
a été procédé cette nuit vers 1h du
matin à la demande du président de
l'université s'est effectué sans
problème ce n'est qu'ultérieurement que
des incidents plus graves sont survenus
et une enquête est en cours mais je
crois que tout ça c'est un
dans mathilde ka-shing c'est ça qui me
frappe depuis le début de toute cette
affaire le gouvernement romand
collectionne les erreurs d'abord il ya
eu le projet devaquet qui est à la
source de beaucoup de choses ensuite le
refus de la concertation et on n'a pas
pu du coup veut dire la difficulté après
une espèce d'incompréhension
à l'égard des jeunes puisque on leur dit
non non on ne s'est pas compris en
réalité il y avait une difficulté
et puis les manifestations de l'autre
jour avec cette espèce de raidir de
roublardise en tout cas de rue dont on
dit on retire me retire pas tout et puis
alors maintenant la violence donc je
crois qu'une série d'erreurs très très
sérieuse qui ont été faites je voudrais
quand même que le gouvernement arrête le
gâchis quand on à finir une bonne chose
de le reconnaître et est maintenant et
c'est ça qu'il faut arrêter ça et on
pouvait éviter ces violences si le
gouvernement avait su entendre ces
jeunes ces lycéens des étudiants qui
manifestaient massivement d'une manière
pacifique parce qu'ils sont inquiets sur
leur avenir ils veulent avoir accès à
l'université et pouvoir ensuite entrer
dans la vie active avec un emploi le
gouvernement ne les a pas entendus et il
porte de ce fait la responsabilité parce
qu'il a je crois il n'a pas saisi le
mouvement profond qu'il ya dans la
jeunesse actuelle la démission de l'un
d'eux alain devaquet vous paraît logique
alors je dois dire auparavant que nous
condamnons ces violences que nous
demandons au gouvernement de s'expliquer
au ministre de l'intérieur de venir
devant l'assemblée nationale
quant à l'émission d'un acte et ont fait
sauter un fusible
mais en aucun cas on pourra rétablir le
courant avec une jeunesse qui
s'inquiètent sur son avenir et que
véritablement prendre les choses en main
en tout état de cause les députés comme
nice sont tout à fait solidaires des
jeunes et des étudiants et condamne
fermement toute violence il faut
d'ailleurs pas confondre des
individualités
quelques personnes du commandement et
l'ensemble du corps policier
mais il y a dans la police
un certain nombre d'éléments
d'extrême-droite qui sont
malheureusement non seulement tolérés
mais encouragé utilisés aux caisses et
dramatique cette mort d'un jeune qui se
bat pour ses convictions
je salue le décès on a social s'associe
à la peine de la bon soir un seul titre
ce soir
les manifestations des jeunes sur fond
de crise politique depuis la nuit
dernière depuis qu'un étudiant a été tué
au quartier latin
la tension est devenue extrême à paris
manifestation dans le calme cet après
midi plus de 20000 personnes mais ce
soir les affrontements ont repris le
quartier latin s'embrase il ya des
barricades boulevard saint-michel et
boulevard saint germain alors tout de
suite le point françois korber roger
motte place saint michel tout à l'heure
peu avant minuit les manifestants ont
mis le feu aux barricades qu'ils avaient
dressé dans la soirée devant les cordons
de crs chargée de barrer l'entrée du
pont saint-michel et voitures renversés
brûlent des scènes de rue violentes
orchestrée par des éléments incontrôlés
qui ont fait dégénérer ce qu'il était au
départ qu'un face à face au quartier
latin sur place un étudiant après celui
là hurle sa colère devant cette violence
les incidents qu'ils aient roule
actuellement sur le quartier
saint-michel n'ont pas été organisées
par des étudiants je suis du service
dedans et ça jamais été les étudiants
qui ont fait ça si des fouteurs de merde
il faut faire gaffe c'est en train de
discréditer le mouvement c'est tout j'ai
eu des manifestations il ya eu des
problèmes avec les flics ok c'est pas
pour ça qu'il faut tout cas s'ils sont
en train de tout [ __ ] en l'air ils
matraquent même les journalistes essaie
de s'approcher en vocations to fork en
plus qu'à le croire les casseurs qui
renverse ces voitures sont en train de
descendre actuellement le boulevard
saint michel en brisant à coups de
barres de fer les vitrines des magasins
les vitres des véhicules en
stationnement
les pompiers qui essaie d'intervenir
sont parfois prises à partie et de
harcèlement des forces de l'ordre et
systématique les forces de l'ordre qui
ont reçu l'ordre d'éviter au maximum les
affrontements et l'emploi des lance
grenades lacrymogènes après la mort la
nuit dernière d'un jeune étudiant rue
monsieur le prince à paris malik
oussékine décédé cette nuit habitait une
petit champ d'une petite chambre du
xviie arrondissement de paris
nos enquêteurs ont rencontré son
propriétaire qui parle de la
personnalité de ce jeune homme c'est un
garçon qui connaissait depuis un an
seulement je l'avais louer une chambre
d'étudiant car il était étudiant et nous
parlions besoin parfois de ses études
ses orientations futures
il était parfait comme présentation
tenez politesse
gentillesse toujours très soignée
d'apparence et jamais je n'aurais
soupçonnait l'utile puisse appartenait à
être militant de quoi que ce soit vous
appartenir à quelques mouvements de ce
soir je comprends pas d'ailleurs ça
l'intéressait beaucoup il a dû être là
par par hasard certainement de mon point
de vue il était irréprochable
tout ce que je peux dire c'est ça et
j'avais même des rapports amicaux avec
l'ue étant donné la différence d'âge des
petits conseils sur le plan des études
et les petites scènes intimes en
chercher dans différentes directions sur
une situation
je crois qu'elles sont seules son
principal souci c'était ça son avenir et
de bien travailler
ce qu'est ce que je peux dire de lutte
quant à françois rigal le jeune
manifestant qui a été blessé lors des
affrontements de jeudi soir à qui a
perdu un oeil qui a également qui est
également victime d'une fracture du
crâne
d'après l'assistance publique ses jours
ne sont plus en danger mais le pronostic
est réservé quant aux séquelles de ses
blessures
mesdemoiselles messieurs bonsoir encore
à la une de l'actualité les
manifestations étudiantes et lycéennes
avec la mort de sept étudiants la nuit
dernière à paris et à ce sujet on a
appris il ya quelques minutes que selon
le procureur de la république de paris
après expertise du corps de marie coup
ce qu' il n'ya pas d'hématomes crâniens
aucune liaison lésions cérébrales et
aucune fracture et trace de violence
observé ne serait pas susceptible
d'avoir entraîné la mort le décès serait
dû à un arrêt cardiaque créé par l'état
pathologique rénale antérieure du
patient cela dit la mort de marie coûts
ce qui n'a suscité une vive émotion et
dans notre région à bordeaux dès 14h cet
après midi a eu lieu une manifestation
spontanée
le reportage de muriel dans guilhem et
jean phlippe furrer quelques jeunes
commencent à se regrouper place de la
victoire
aucune manifestation n'était prévue
c'est par téléphone que certains ont
décidé de se réunir ici cet après-midi
[Musique]
spontanée qui s'est formée et eux donc
par des contacts téléphoniques des gens
puisqu'on est c'est tout le monde est
venu manifester
je ne pourrais voter contre
man 2
du jeune manifestant
on travaille les membres du comité de
grève lancé des appels à la population
pour qu'elle se joigne à leur cortège en
direction de la préfecture de région
tous les étudiants ressentent
profondément ont d'une part de la
tristesse de constater que leur
mouvement qui étaient pacifiques qui
souhaitait poser des problèmes deux ans
le gouvernement tourne comme ça qu'on
soit obligé de constater les mots et
quelle est votre réaction à la suite de
la démission dossier levac et je crois
que la démission de monsieur dollar qui
nous étaient différentes c'était le
projet que nous contestions que le porte
parole du projet sont monsieur de vin
qu'il soit monsieur maurice à nous est
indifférent c'est le projet que nous
contestons nous demandons le retrait de
ce projet est que de même ce soit
monsieur monory monsieur chirac il
éléphants ne nous est complètement
différent ils seront deux à trois cents
à défiler dans les rues piétonnes
une marche silencieuse seuls certains
par mégaphone explique les raisons de la
manifestation
à 17h30 le cortège arrive devant la
préfecture protégée par un cordon de
police l'ordre de dispersion et à leur
donner tout s'est déroulé sans incident
dans le plus grand calme
dans ce contexte monsieur alain devaquet
ministre déléguée chargée de la
recherche et de l'enseignement supérieur
a présenté ce matin sa démission au chef
du gouvernement matignon explique qu'il
a été informé de l'offre de démission de
monsieur devaquet mais la réponse de
monsieur chirac et n'interviendra
qu'après son retour de londres qui est
située en début d'après-midi le parcours
politique de monsieur devaquet et sa
personnalité
estelle bluesy et jamais un des rares
universitaires du gouvernement alain
devaquet 44 ans soucieux de l'avenir de
l'université des étudiants auraient sans
doute préféré convaincre qu'imposer
chaque fois qu'il en eut l'occasion
pendant le déroulement de la crise il
s'est voulu avant tout à l'écouté des
jeunes
je connais votre travail et je puis dire
que comme universitaire depuis dix ans
j'ai vu les étudiants à l'ibsr
travailler avec de plus en plus de
sérieux
le problème qui me choque c'est que une
fois rentrée à l'université
il faut pas que l'étudiant père de son
temps il faut donc qu'ils soient bien
orienté physicien professeur alain
devaquet s'est rendue un jour de janvier
77 au siège du rpr pour prendre sa carte
tout naturellement les problèmes de
recherche et d'énergie nous sont confiés
jacques chirac des celles visant lui
l'oiseau rare et le propulse contre
toute attente au secrétariat général du
rpr pris entre les feux des jeunes
chiraquiens et des vieux baron
l'intellectuel se sent mal à l'aise il
perd son siège de député en 80 mais sort
victorieux des municipales de 83 en
remportant la mairie du xième
arrondissement en mars dernier jacques
chirac lui confie le portefeuille de sa
compétence
la recherche et les universités et voilà
de nouveau le modéré aux prises avec les
ultra libéraux de la majorité
d'abord dans la sphère du cnrs qu'il se
refuse à démanteler et puis et surtout
sur la réforme des universités
une loi qu'il signe de son nom malgré
les points qu'ils ont tous été arrachés
des points contestés par les étudiants
et que lui-même désavouant privé
paradoxalement alain devaquet devenu
l'homme à abattre le symbole de la
sélection aux yeux des jeunes incompris
il demande aujourd'hui à quitter le
gouvernement
tout en sachant pourtant qu'il n'a
jamais oublié le boursier fils de
boulanger qu'il a été le calme aussi le
recueillement et surtout pas de
débordements tels étaient les mots
d'ordre des jeunes gens qui avaient
choisi de défiler aujourd'hui en signe
de deuil après la mort du jeune malik
oussékine environ 3000 personnes cet
après midi dans les rues de paris un
cortège on parlait aussi beaucoup bien
sûr du retrait du projet de loi
le reportage de poing cornet et olivier
lerner dernier défilé de la sorbonne à
la bastille pour malik oussékine trente
mille étudiants et lycéens parfaitement
silencieux parfaitement digne aucun cri
aucun slogan pas la moindre banderole
les graffitis sur les murs parlent d'eux
mêmes
c'est dorénavant
le gouvernement devra discuter avec nous
et c'est pour cela que c'est une
victoire
néanmoins ça a coûté très cher je pense
est trop chère la vie d'un homme c'est
beaucoup trop pour un projet de loi pour
un peu d'encre un peu de papier je pense
on a eu une note de satisfaction du côté
du projet devaquet mais pour ce qui est
de nos copains qui sont morts enfin
notre copain activement et les autres
qui sont eux qui ont été blessés
on continue à manifester de toute façon
des dizaines de mains anonymes ont
déposé des couronnes de fleurs rue
monsieur le prince
là même où malik est tombé regroupés
derrière une simple couronne de roses
blanches
le cortège est passé ensuite devant
l'hôpital cochin pour rejoindre enfin la
place de la bastille aucun incident
n'est venu troubler la manifestation un
simple refrain a été entendu au moment
de la dispersion devaquet on l'a eu
monory on leur a
même monsieur bonsoir
fin du projet de loi devaquet
aujourd'hui à 13 heures pour être précis
des manifestations ont eu lieu dans
toute la région à la mémoire d'alexis
cecchin étudiants mort samedi dernier à
paris à vesoul en haute-saône ce matin
600 lycéens ont effectué une marche
silencieuse cet après midi 200 élèves du
lep luxembourg déposé une gerbe alors
que 450 lycéens degré et luxeuil
défilaient dans les rues chez à besançon
les mêmes manifestations ont eu lieu
dans le calme et la dignité
la voix de jacques chirac dans les haut
parleurs de la fac de lettres a appris
aux étudiants le retrait du projet de
loi devaquet les applaudissements ont
salué cette déclaration mais pas
d'explosion de joie la mort de malik ses
fils pèse encore très fort sur le coeur
de l'étudiant si forte
une forte joueurs mais enfin beaucoup
d'amertume parce que je trouve que ce
n'est pas très normal d'en être arrivé
là et qu'il y ait fait lui qui en mars
pour que le gouvernement chirac
chrétienne de projets de métier à 16
heures la place saint-pierre est noire
de monde à la mémoire de manip ses
filles le silence sera le seul mot
d'ordre
pourtant dans la foule on commence déjà
à tirer des bilans du mouvement il
aurait pu devenir une autre façon de
faire de la politique car en france
justement sans pour autant une bonne
partie d'entre elles
et montrer que des gens qui ont des
choses à dire et qui peuvent tous
peuvent agir à 16h15 le cortège
s'ébranle toujours dans le silence
[Musique]
les étudiants les lycéens sont
maintenant confrontés à l'avenir délicat
de ceux qui viennent de remporter une
victoire leur nombre aujourd'hui encore
le court le soulagement se mélange à
l'anxiété
que va devenir le mouvement pourront-ils
se faire entendre à l'occasion de la
consultation nationale promise par le
gouvernement
plus directement personne ne sait
actuellement si la grève et la
manifestation de mercredi seront
maintenues mais supprimée
mais au delà des prospectives et des
suppositions reste la tristesse de lutte
depuis trois jours a dépassé les
étudiants la violence il ne l'avait pas
voulu le cortège de cet après-midi
enterrer les illusions d'une jeunesse
pleine de générosité
[Musique]
à la préfecture ce soir veniez un
silence hurlant de dépit et d'amertume
une manifestation impressionnante de
dignité que l'on soutienne non leur
mouvement
une chose est sûre ce soir une partie de
la jeunesse française est entrée en
politique dans le sens noble du terme
puis la manifestation qui doit avoir
lieu mercredi prochain au niveau
national est maintenu
alors bien sûr attentif à ces derniers
développements les étudiants se
préparent toujours à leur manifestation
de demain il devait écouter ce soir
j'imagine avec beaucoup d'attention
monsieur mitterrand c'est un mouvement
qui se veut calme demain et qui tente
ans qui entend dénoncer avant tout la
répression avec quand même le chaud
froid de plusieurs syndicats qui au
terme d'une valse hésitation ont décidé
ce soir de se joindre au mouvement
c'est vrai par exemple pour la fen et
pour la cfdt le point tout de suite
you may grégoire ce matin à jussieu à la
coordination nationale on appelait à une
manifestation du souvenir à une
manifestation de la vigilance de main
dans les rues de paris et aussi de
province souvenir de malik
et puis celui de la violence face à un
mouvement contestataire qui se voulait
pacifique vigilance aussi sur l'avenir
des universités puisque le gouvernement
entend maintenant ouvrir le dialogue
bureau a été désigné pour la première
fois mardi dernier si le bureau de la
coordination a décidé de maintenir la
journée de mercredi
c'est pour exprimer dans le plus grand
calme
l'idée suivante plus jamais ça plus
jamais de projet devaquet ou de projet x
med de vaquer plus jamais de répression
morts blessés lorsque la jeunesse
manifestent dans le calme et la sérénité
pour son avenir
c'est apparemment ces slogans qui ont
fait basculer la décision de la faim ni
la cfdt
ces deux organisations al'inverse de la
cgt avait annoncé qu'elle ne
participerait pas à la manifestation
finalement elles seront présentes demain
la fen hier au bureau fédéral a appris
en cours de journée que monsieur chirac
retirer le projet devaquet à partir de
là la fin était amené à dire très
clairement elle ne lance plus son mot
d'ordre de grève générale de tous les
personnels ication et par ailleurs elles
ne participent pas à la manifestation du
10 dans des conditions où elle était
prévue par contre elle est prête à
participer à toute manifestation
concernant la défense des droits de
l'homme et en mémoire des victimes de la
répression
et puis maître kiejman l'avocat de la
famille du jeune malik mort dans la nuit
de vendredi à la suite d'un violent
matraquage maître kiejman conteste la
version officielle sur les conditions de
la mort du jeune homme
après avoir eu communication
du dossier nous avons pu voir dans ce
dossier une déclaration du médecin
régulateur du samu dont je vous lis les
quelques lignes
parlant d' malik le médecin régulateur
dit ceci au moment des faits cette
personne n'est pas victime d'un malaise
cardiaque mais a dû recevoir un coup
derrière la tête
je considère cette personne comme
cliniquement décédé il serait cependant
préférable de ne pas communiquer cette
information à la foule je propose
d'emmener cette personne à l'hôpital
cochin en réanimation aux urgences
chirurgie afin d'éviter tout incident or
je déplore que cette information n'ait
pas fait partie du communiqué se voulant
objectifs du procureur de la république
samedi
madame monsieur bonsoir
le calme et le recueillement c'était le
dernier hommage qu'ils pouvaient et
qu'ils ont voulu rendre à malik ils
étaient très nombreux étudiants lycéens
parents professeurs syndicaliste jeunes
et moins jeunes à défiler aujourd'hui
dans les rues de paris
comme toujours les chiffres varient
selon qu'ils proviennent des
organisateurs ou de laponie cela va de
six cent mille manifestants à 126 milles
en tout cas un cortège imposant pour un
seul mot d'ordre plus jamais cela le
récit de cette journée avec rachid arhab
et olivier lerner
de denfert rochereau à la nation ils ont
pas sur les boulevards parisiens les
traces de la mort cortège silencieux
volontairement silencieux peu de
banderoles ou à l'or noir noir comme un
crêpe de deuil le deuil de malik
oussekine mort après un violent
matraquage la semaine dernière le même
jour cap del benyahia tué par un
policier livre à pantin l'oim des
manifestations étudiantes
les organisateurs avaient malgré tout
tenu à associer ces deux morts symbole
pour eux de la même violence policière
unité des étudiants et des lycéens
contre la violence mais il n'était pas
seul
des syndicats ont tenu à être à leur
côté la cgt la cfdt la fédération de
l'éducation nationale des hommes
politiques
aussi pour éviter tout dérapage entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre
des magistrats des avocats des médecins
un casque blanc sur la tête
tout un symbole arrivée place de la
nation alors que la fin du cortège
démarre est à peine de denfert rochereau
six kilomètres plus haut les
manifestants se sont rassemblés pour
écouter de très nombreux témoignages
dont celui de la famille ou cei keane
qui a reçu des télégrammes de soutien
venus de l'europe entière
ils valent aussi aujourd'hui c'est vers
toute la population qui s'est senti
concerné et pour ne pas oublier
elle est avec nous il faut une
commission d'orchestre indépendante afin
de faire la lumière sur les
responsabilités de ces spéciaux
dispersion sans aucun incident jusqu'à
présent les étudiants ont réussi leur
pari une manifestation de masse sans
violence voilà tout était donc calme ce
soir tout est donc calme ce soir mais la
mobilisation n'était pas limité à paris
il y avait d'autres cortèges tout aussi
calme et recueillie dans les grandes
villes de province ou étudiants haïtiens
avaient appelé à manifester le point
province avec jean-michel mercurol plus
jamais ça on proclame mais aussi
étudiants et lycéens aujourd'hui au
cours de défilé le plus souvent
silencieux dans de nombreuses villes de
province dans drôles de deuil à
marseille pour un cortège digne en
souvenir de malik 15000 manifestants à
lyon avec pancartes et slogans pour s'en
prendre au ministre de l'intérieur
tandis qu'à bordeaux le cortège s'est
achevée par un sit in devant les rares
forces de l'ordre à nancy et à metz
les sidérurgistes lorrains étaient venus
apporter leur soutien aux jeunes
manifestants en tout selon l' afp près
de deux cent mille personnes ont
manifesté dans 36 villes de france à la
mémoire de malik oussékine et oui le
défilé donc à la mémoire de malik au
moment même où les circonstances de sa
mort et est évoqué à l'assemblée
nationale lors des questions d'actualité
face à face l'ancien premier ministre
pierre mauroy et le ministre de
l'intérieur charles pasqua
c'était un étudiant comme tous les
autres il s'appelait malik
et c'est bien là une des réalités de la
france d'aujourd'hui
depuis l'école maternelle jusqu'à
l'université
les enfants de france d'où qu'il vienne
travailler ensemble reconnaît ccem il
n'est pas question pour eux d'exclure
aux rouches ap
et pas davantage yasmina ou malik
[Applaudissements]
votre rôle est le maintien de l'ordre
dans notre pays on endredi soir on a vu
la police frapper un homme est mort
samedi soir on a vu des policiers
manifestement sans or laisser faire les
casseurs pendant plusieurs heures
pourquoi monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur ce que j'ai à dire c'est que
ça fait vraiment récupération
politicienne
[Applaudissements]
suite
c'est ça
ensuite
ensuite c'est vrai que la mort de ce
jeune étudiant nous a tous touchés et
vous n'avez ni le monopole du coeur ni
celui de la générosité
mais non nice lui mais non mais ni celui
de l'intelligence lors de grandes
manifestations ni connaissent des
incidents il est toujours reproché aux
forces de l'ordre soient d'intervenir
trop tôt soit de réagir avec lenteur les
instructions données n'autorise en aucun
cas ce type de critiques
elle visait à la fois et éviter que
l'intervention des forces de l'ordre
n'est pour effet d'alimenter les
premiers incidents et à faciliter
l'interpellation des casseurs qui
poursuivent leurs déprédations
après que le gros des manifestants
soient dispersées